the concept of instant messaging crossed
into the mainstream in the 1990s
allowing friends acquaintances
colleagues and like-minded thinkers from
all over the world to connect in real
time
since then instant messaging has
revolutionized how we communicate and
today over a billion people are signed
up for at least one messaging app
the present instant messaging experience
is seamless and it intuitively
integrates features like video photos
voice ecommerce and gaming with plain
old messaging
among these apps whatsapp has
comfortably found its place among the
most popular messaging platforms
like everyone associated with the
internet a matter of security is never
far away considering the huge user base
of this messaging app hackers are always
on the lookout for compromised accounts
to grab
today we are going to cover some of the
ways we can protect our whatsapp account
from falling into malicious hands
we start by learning about the
importance of security when it comes to
whatsapp and instant messaging apps in
general
next we cover some of the most important
steps that should be followed in order
to protect our whatsapp accounts from
hackers
finally we learn what we should do when
a whatsapp account gets compromised
let's start by learning why we need to
focus on the safety of whatsapp
in the year of 2020 the big news was
about amazon ceo jeff bezos and his
phone being hacked by saudi arabia
a report coming from the guardian
suggested that bezos phone was hacked
via a video file sent on whatsapp
the report said that bezos mobile phone
was hacked by saudi arabian prince in
the year 2018 and gigabyte's worth of
data was stolen from the device
while there are some issues being raised
about the report which states with the
medium to high confidence that jeff
bezos phone was hacked it does raise a
security fear for regular users
after all if the phone of one of the
world's most powerful men can be hacked
the same can happen to any one of us as
well
when it comes to regular users we
exchange messages with our loved ones
regarding a paradigm of topics
the information which may seem trivial
initially can later function as
ammunition for a campaign regarding
identity theft
basic information like preferred banks
occasional dining places can go a long
way in social engineering attacks
further increasing the need for secure
messaging habits
whatsapp uses end-to-end encryption to
protect all communication on its
platform
these encryption keys not only make it
impossible to decrypt messages but they
also prevent third parties and even
whatsapp from accessing messages or
calls
but not entirely
although end-to-end encryption makes
whatsapp more secure than other
communication apps no app is 100 safe to
use
like any application or digital device
whatsapp is often targeted by bad actors
it also has access to your contacts and
tracks where and how long you use it
putting your privacy and personal
information at risk
we all have access to our cell phones so
it's no surprise that sms two factor
authentication is one of the most
widespread types of mfa available you
don't need any apps or digital keys and
it's not tied to a specific ecosystem
unfortunately it's also not a secure
multi-factor authentication method
the nature of sms itself opens up your
organization to a host of lists
hackers may have many ways to leverage
sms to find a way into your accounts and
network
be it via spoofed sim cards or message
hijacking whatsapp2fa using sms isn't a
foolproof solution
now that we understand the variety of
reasons why whatsapp needs extra
security let's go through some of the
ways we can achieve this
it is more than probable that one fine
day you might receive a whatsapp message
or even an sms that reads that your
order is delayed please check its data
here or your account is locked and
please unlock it here or even some
tempting messages like win free 3g and
movie tickets here
some of them may sound intimidating and
some of them may be lucrative but they
all have one purpose to trick you into
clicking that link and once you do that
it's already over
it will install malware on your phone
and you won't have a clue about it only
when you start noticing that your phone
bills are abnormally high or your bank
account has been used without your
permission the realization will dawn
upon you that something is wrong with
your phone but by then it may be too
late
whatsapp in itself provides various
privacy options to users
the messaging platform provides users
with option to choose who they want to
share their profile photo status and
other details with
it's a good idea to change the settings
to contacts only this means only phone
numbers that are saved on your
smartphone will be able to see your
profile photo status phone number and
auto delete status as well
make sure you enable the option to lock
the screen every time whatsapp is closed
this will ensure no one else but you can
open your whatsapp account
just head to the settings menu privacy
and select the screen lock option you
will then need to register your
fingerprint after the process is
completed you will have to scan your
fingerprint every time you open the
whatsapp app this adds an extra layer of
security
the two-step verification works as an
extra layer of security and helps
whatsapp users to protect their otps and
documents shared through whatsapp it's
very easy to set up a pin to activate as
2 step verification users have to enter
it periodically once it is activated
whatsapp will sometimes keep asking
users to enter the 6 digit passcode
users cannot disable this without
disabling the two-step verification
feature altogether
in case users do not provide whatsapp
with an email id and want to disable
two-step verification then the number
will be permitted to re-verify on
whatsapp without the passcode after 7
days however the users will lose all
pending messages upon re-verifying
we often have the tendency to log into
whatsapp web at the office and then
leave the account open on the desktop
this habit can actually create problems
for you someone else sitting on the same
pc can access all your chats without you
even realizing it
it's a good practice to log out from
whatsapp before leaving the office it
just takes a few seconds to log in again
by just scanning the code and you're
done
all whatsapp user should ensure that the
chats are end to end encrypted to verify
that a chat is end-to-end encrypted open
the chat tap on the name of the contact
to open the contact info screen and then
tap encryption to view the qr code and a
60-digit number
whatsapp end-to-end encryption ensures
that only you and your contact can read
the messages that are being exchanged
and nobody in between not even whatsapp
with the necessary guidelines out of the
way let us go through the recommended
course of action should our whatsapp
accounts be compromised
the first and most important thing that
you need to do is report the issue to
the whatsapp support team for assistance
make sure that you reach out to the
support team through its help desk and
report the hacking attempt
whatsapp help center will take the
shortest time to resolve your issue via
email or within the app itself
this will help you to take prompt legal
action against the hackers if you can't
access your email call the support team
in some cases the support will
deactivate your whatsapp account and
request you to reactivate it within 30
days if you don't want it to be deleted
completely
when someone compromises your whatsapp
account they can now send messages to
your contacts stating that the company
sent your verification code and gain
access to the account
that's why one of the first things
you'll want to do is send a message to
your friends and family letting them
know that you've lost access to your
account this action prevents further
exploitation of your account and others
another reason you'll want to let your
contacts know you have no access to your
whatsapp account is that they may fish
for personal information
from your banking number to your email
address hackers will cleverly attempt to
gain as much access to your personal
information as possible
whatsapp web is an extension of whatsapp
messenger over the web that facilitates
easy synchronization of our smartphone
and personal computer
this is the biggest security thread that
hackers can easily exploit to get into
your personal data over whatsapp
therefore it is highly recommended that
you use this whatsapp feature carefully
once you notice that your whatever
messenger has been hacked go to your
whatsapp web and tap or click on the
logout from all computers option this
will deactivate all the web extensions
of your account
under the unfortunate circumstances
where the account recovery doesn't seem
likely you can always ask whatsapp
support to delete your account
permanently
while far from the ideal solution it can
act as a fail-safe option if you want to
protect your personal data at any cost
possible you can always open a new
account later with the security issues
mitigated
hope you learned something new today
if you have any questions regarding
today's session please let us know below
and we will be happy to answer your
queries subscribe to our channel for
more videos like this thank you for
watching
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here